eastband fan
and now on book tv more from the
virginia festival of the book this 22nd
annual event took place in
charlottesville last week and featured
many authors
today we bring you marjorie cohn on the
use of drone warfare a panel on
pandemics around the world
and we kick off the day with kelly
carlin a radio personality and daughter
of the late comedian and social critic
george carlin good morning
thank you all for coming today for what
i think you're going to enjoy
uh very much my name is josh wheeler i'm
the director of the thomas jefferson
center for the protection of free
expression we are the host of this
program today
it's a source of great pride for us at
the center
that
this is the 22nd virginia festival of
the book and the center has been
involved in one way or another with all
22
festivals and it's something that we
hope to continue to do
um for many years to come because i
think one of the best ways to combat
uh censorship or the desire
to censor a speech we don't like is to
remind people of the many benefits that
we receive from free speech and by
having this kind of festival celebrating
the right of free speech
is i think a way to remind folks well
it's it's a small price to pay
when sometimes we have to hear cups some
things that we might not want to hear
for all the benefits of being able to
explore any idea any theme
and
any concept
without any fear of government reprisals
so yeah
there we go
she knows this applause for the first
amendment now i know that that 22 years
it was actually in this very room that i
discovered that i needed to wear glasses
because
at some point i don't know it was three
or four festivals in i found myself
doing this number you know they asked me
to read some housekeeping details at the
beginning and so i brought this up and
then
[Laughter]
so you'll have to
ask me uh uh be patient with me with my
glasses on
but
um i do want to to tell you that this is
uh the virginia festival of the book
obviously which is uh
the product of the virginia foundation
for the humanities i've been asked to
ask everybody in the audience to please
silence their cell phones not just for
us but this is going to be recorded
and if you would like to tweet about
this event you can do so at hashtag va
book 2016
and i say that as if i have any idea
what it means
and if you're going to tweet about this
event include me i am at kelly
underscore carlin please
she could be speaking a foreign language
right now i have no idea actually i know
a little bit about that kelly's actually
a very
proficient tweeter with quite a number
how many followers do you have
now almost 30 000 wow
so supporting the festival the festival
is free of charge not free of cost
please remember to go online and give
back or pick up a giving envelope from
the information desk at the omni and
support your festival so we may sustain
it for many more years to come
evaluations please fill out program
evaluations these provide useful
information that help keep the festival
free and open to the public you can fill
out a paper evaluation before you leave
or complete it online at
vabook.org
survey i do know what that means
after this event after the end of this
program we are going to have uh books
available for sale right down here and i
think we could prevail upon our guest
our author uh to sign a copy if you'd
like i think that'll be happening okay
we are here today to talk about
this book
a carlin home companion growing up with
george
and we will talk a little bit about
about that in the future as i said the
center's been involved in many of these
programs
in the past and i've i've had the great
pleasure to moderate them
a number of them
i realized though probably about the
third or fourth time that people weren't
here to hear me
they were actually more interested in
hearing about the book or the author and
so i have learned that the best
questions actually come from the
audience itself so i am going to very
early on stop asking the questions and
make
the
the envelope of the envelope the
microphone available to you folks and
will bring the microphone around to
anybody who who has a question
i told kelly that i can i can ask
questions if this audience doesn't have
any but
i have never found that to be a problem
with charlottesville audience um and i
can blah blah blah
for anyone but let me tell you a little
bit about our author today
um kelly carlin has written for film tv
and most recently the stage
her critically acclaimed solo show a
carlin home companion her master's
degree in counseling psychology from
pacifica graduate institute informs her
work as an author speaker workshop
leader and citizen of earth she lives in
los angeles with her husband bob mccall
and their jack russell terrier stella
but dreams of living somewhere with a
lot fewer cars someday
as long as you avoid 29 north i think
charlottesville catch that bill
perfectly
will you please join me in welcoming
kelly carlin
i should also say
very very proud of the fact that kelly
carlin is on the thomas jefferson
center's board of
trustees very happy to be a strong
believer in free speech yes and we're
thrilled to have her
to help direct the center's efforts
but first question yes
what compelled you to write
your book
um well
it's interesting
i've been wanting to write and tell my
story for about 15 well now
that would be 17 years it's funny how
that does the time thing does that like
that
uh
my mom died in 97 and after she she died
pretty suddenly pretty quickly
diagnosed with liver cancer was dead
five weeks later
pretty shocking a huge wake-up call for
me as a human as an artist as all sorts
of things and
i'd had this
wild and crazy life i was 34 35 at that
time and i had already had i felt like i
already had lived seven lives and
uh i i wanted to tell
my story my survivor story because at 35
i was a very different person than i was
at 25
or at 20 or 15 or 10 i mean there's just
so many different iterations of my life
with my family and then my life
uh
as as an adult or what i was pretending
to be an adult at least
uh
and so i wanted to tell my survivor
story uh and i knew that yeah okay so
it's a little hook there a little
interesting i happen to be george
carlin's daughter and yes part of my
story is
um
quite fun with my dad and my mom in the
60s and the 70s
uh and in the 80s and all the way
through to my until my dad's death but
i had you know my parents had drug and
alcohol issues when i was a child until
i was 12 my mother was an alcoholic she
almost died she got sober
there was a lot of
money and cocaine and fame in my house
with all the weird stuff that comes
along with that some great stories
around that which maybe we'll share
today and so i i i'd lived through that
we our family had lived through that
my father's heart disease my mother's
breast cancer
uh i'd gotten involved in some abusive
relationships my own drug addiction
panic attack syndrome i'd been through a
lot of stuff
and
i
felt like because i had gotten through
it and found
a way to get my feet back on the ground
and find my center finally that i really
wanted to share that
with the world i wanted to
i don't know pay it forward in some way
i was such so lucky to be grow up in the
family that i grew up even though it was
pretty chaotic for quite a few years
but i understood my privilege and uh so
i wanted to share that i i wanted to
expand share as i say in aa your
experience strength and hope
and that's part of the reason why i
wanted to write the book
now that i've written it and i've been
sitting with it and kind of looking back
on it and talking a lot about it the
last five or six months
i also see that being an only child
growing up in the shadow of fame
growing up in a family where the adults
chaos was in charge of my life until i
was 12 years old
i didn't feel like i had
a real voice or a place
in the world and i see now that telling
my story is a way for me to
to heal that ultimately to say i exist
i'm here i matter like we all do every
single one of us has a story to tell
and uh
and
and so i can see that it's on some level
that there's uh that that issue it
that's one of the themes in the book
invisibility visibility is is one of the
themes i talk about
and i see now that um
that that's part of it too is just
something about being seen and heard
which all children want ultimately so
so here i am being seen and heard big
time
[Laughter]
well
i want this program to be very much
about about your book because it's a
fascinating book as you say survivor's
tale and but a big part of that of
course is is your parents yes and um
and you're a writer you've written for
stage for screen for
publication yes and and i can only
assume that you
inherited that um in some part from your
father who
loved who loved the written word
actually inherited
inherited from the karlin family itself
well that's what i was going to ask is
is was did that start with your father
or there's a great story in the book
about perhaps where he he got his love
yeah i have to have to find out where
that story is but um but
um
carlin family word irish
uh gift of the gab and all that stuff
my dad's father patrick carlin my dad
didn't really know his father
his father couldn't uh
metabolize ethanol very well as my
father used to say
and uh when he wasn't drinking he was a
brilliant man he was a big advertising
guy in new york city sold advertising
for all the big papers
uh like national level salesmen
brilliant salesman and also
won speaking contests uh you know dale
carnegie and stuff like that national
speaking awards
had a real gift for it
my dad never knew him though because
his mother my dad's mother mary
when my dad was about three months old
took uh my father
and his older brother patrick and snuck
down the fire escape because she was
tired of being
battered around by patrick senior and
patrick senior had started battering
around
young patrick too and she wanted to
protect my father from that so there was
the gift of the gab from that and then
mary
was an amazing storyteller she was
someone who would take a bus ride
downtown and back up town and have a
full story about who was on the bus
beginning middle and end
punch line the whole thing uh really a
very funny witty woman and
there's a little story here of
my dad
uh
here i'll just read a little bit of this
on may 12 1937 george dennis patrick
carlin was born
eight weeks later after months of trying
to make the marriage work mary sneaked
out the fire escape in the middle of the
night with her two young boys leaving
patrick carlin senior and his rage for
good
she'd seen the damage that her husband
had already done to little patrick and
she was not going to let sweet george be
another victim
this time it stuck she tried to leave
him a few times before
even though patrick tried to woo her
back she held strong george never saw
his dad again
in 1945 his father died of a massive
heart attack at the age of 57 my dad was
eight years old
without a man around to keep my dad out
of trouble on the streets of the upper
west side of manhattan or what he and
his friends like to call irish harlem
mary took her job as both mother and
father very seriously she looked for
ways to shape and control young george's
mind and life
she succeeded in only one area
a love of language and words
mary occur mary encouraged my dad to
look up words he didn't know in the
dictionary and then use them in
conversation
one morning young george wanting to show
off a new word he had learned excitedly
asked his mother if she had perused the
paper that morning
he anticipated her approval
slowly she turned sharpened her gaze
onto him and said
i have not
actually i've only given it a cursory
glance
george chagrined turned around and
marched right back to the dictionary to
learn the new word cursory
that was mary carlin in a nutshell uh
loved to be the have the upper hand in
every situation
but she did she encouraged my dad my
dad's love of language big time and my
dad encouraged me too
uh with a love of language
um he used to do this thing
well into my 30s too i might add which
was very irritating
if i was with him and having we were
with people or whatever in conversation
and i would pronounce a word
wrong
he would slip me a piece of paper later
with the
correct pronunciation like written out
like it does in the dictionary you know
and i would just i mean i get it dad was
trying to protect me and make sure i
sounded smart and everything like that
but into your 30s at some point you're
like dad i'm i'm just feeling a little
[Laughter]
not so great about that um
i'd love to just read a little bit of
the beginning here of my book too just
to jump back a little bit because um
there's something about my life that
i don't know has always felt faded in
some way and i just want to read a
little to you a little bit about
um
about that
carlin legend holds that all it took for
me to come into the world was
a little sperm a little egg a little
scotch a little weed
and something called the limbo
we've been trying to get pregnant for
months but no luck explained my mom to
me seven-year-old kelly as i sat on the
bed watching my dad pack for the road
just moments earlier he said to me
when i'm down in new orleans i'll get a
postcard from the hotel you were
conceived in and send it to you
confused by the word conceived i looked
at my mom and she quickly filled in the
details
well you see we were down in new orleans
uh must have been what october 62. we
were at a club hanging out with some
musicians we'd met when someone
announced a limbo contest well it
sounded like fun and so i did it next
thing i knew i was pregnant
mom didn't mention the weed or scotch in
her telling of my fateful beginning
because
she didn't need to
they were a given
oh sorry about that they were a given
dad had been smoking weed and drinking
beer since he was 14 and mom started
sneaking sips off her daddy's drinks at
around the same age
and as far as the limbo goes i'm still
not clear about the mechanics of it all
but that's never mattered it clearly
worked i am here
for the two years leading up to the
night of the limbo my mom brenda and my
dad george had been constant companions
starving artists and comrades in arms
chasing my dad's comedy dreams
they did hell gigs packed and unpacked
their suitcases hundreds of times and
traveled to almost every state in the
country in their 57 dodged art
my mom loved playing the role of on the
road partner in crime to my dad's rebel
artist on a mission
she was dad's lover party girl and press
agent all rolled into one his full
partner in life
and always his best audience
you could always hear her great laugh
above the din of clinking glasses and
mumbling patrons in every club they
visited
because dad was a complete unknown on
some nights she was the only person in
the audience
one night in baltimore
no one was in the audience
not even my mom my dad asked the club
owner um
so exactly why am i going on
because you know if people come in i
want them to know we got some
entertainment
i hear dad killed that night
[Laughter]
during those lean years dad paid his
dues but also got lucky
one night lenny bruce caught his act in
chicago loved what he saw and introduced
him to his manager murray becker
this was huge my dad worshipped lenny
taking every opportunity to soak up
lenny's presence my mom and dad would
drive from new york to the gate of horn
club in chicago
just to see him perform
one night while they were there lenny
got arrested halfway through his set
this had become the norm that night the
cops did not like the use of his word
i'll not say that because we're doing tv
here
it's a
very descriptive word
looking to hassle the club the cops
began to ask everyone for their ids when
they got to my dad he defiantly told
them um yeah i don't believe in
identification
and the cops promptly threw him into the
back of the paddy wagon with lenny
when my dad proudly told lenny what he
had done lenny looked at him and said
what are you a schmuck
my mom chased that paddy wagon by foot
all the way to the police station that
night and bailed them out of jail
growing up surrounded by stories like
these and living through many others
myself i've always felt as if my
family's journey has unfolded like some
kind of mythological legend
our lives together have felt shaped by a
force threads of fate or maybe even what
my dad called the big electron
something was calling us forth and
interweaving exactly the right people
places and things to form one amazing
life together
it's just always seemed so destined
so maybe we should talk a little bit
about the first amendment
what
well i do want to do we could talk about
that now or we could i also want to talk
about sort of the next phase
after your conception
one of the things i love about and so i
definitely will talk about first
amendment particularly uh how we met i
want to share that anecdote but one of
the things i really love about your book
is um
uh you i think you s did you spend some
time in the the titles uh oh the
chapters yes oh sure of course yeah yeah
yeah and and one of the i think really
uh
enlightening ones in terms of your youth
uh
is the the three musketeers the chapter
title the three musketeers and the sort
of that part of your life yeah and i
thought if you could share a little sure
absolutely so because i was an only
child there were only three of us and
early on at some point my dad began
calling us the three musketeers
um all for one one for all and and that
became a real theme um
well i mean you know when you're an only
child in any of a tight-knit family like
that you feel like it's sometimes like
the three of you just kind of against
the you and you against the world kind
of a thing and it felt like that
sometimes certainly in our lives uh
especially in the 70s when
my dad was considered a hippie freak and
it felt like the whole world was against
us on some level uh but this also became
a theme in our life in a sense that
um
you know if you grow up in a
dysfunctional family and i'm sure none
of you here haven't understand what i'm
talking about
uh there's a sense of loyalty to your
family that happens and there's a
willingness to
um
keep your family secrets for your family
to keep them protected to because you
love them because it's the right thing
to do in the moment uh because you want
to protect your family's reputation and
you don't want to tell strangers what's
going on at your house
and so there's a there's a sense of that
in my family of you know when you when
you grow up and there was some
crazy stuff going on um
in our household
and uh i'm just looking here for a
little bit of this
this
um
this sense of the three musketeers
uh
you know it was a great
sense
of
belonging in that way and yet it also
kept our alcoholic family secrets secret
and i don't think helped us in the la in
the long run
uh a lot of crazy stuff went on in my
house
uh around that and uh
but there's a warmth to it that um
i do i do love and adore and actually i
was i went to my that my book launched
the barnes noble in la um someone came
to me and gave me a little
um hot wheels car that had the three
musketeers on it little three musketeers
and i just i just i it's on my it's on
my like in my little altar i just so
covered it so much um
but i'd like to give a little read here
a little bit about
uh kind of what us carl what we carlins
were doing in in the the summer of 1972
uh to give you an idea of um how
important it was to be the three
musketeers
in the summer of 1972 mom and i went on
the road with dad
the road was always a fun adventure some
of my earliest memories from the road
are waking up in a hotel room with
both my parents dead to the world and
spending the next few hours coloring
watching cartoons with the volume all
the way down and staring out the window
at the city below
finally when i was starving i'd nudge my
parents awake dad would run down to a
local diner or store or as he got more
successful order room service and buy a
bunch of those mini boxes of rice
krispies and a quart of milk
he'd then carefully take out his pocket
knife cut open those teeny boxes and
magically transform them into an instant
bowl
abracadabra breakfast was served
and although i'd never heard it i'm
absolutely sure that it was one of those
mornings that my dad heard that famous
snap crackle
you
[Laughter]
our first stop that summer was kent
state
my dad took me to the memorial for the
four college kids that had been shot by
the national guard a few years before
he explained that they've been
protesting against the war standing up
for what they believed in and that the
government had silenced them by shooting
them
this was one of those daddy's big
teaching moments
he wanted me to understand the
importance of people standing up for
what they believed in especially those
who were willing to stand up for their
government to make their point he
explained how the government had always
silenced those who did not have a voice
to begin with blacks and native
americans especially and how young white
american girls and boys were now in that
category too
i felt there was no safe place for
anyone
being a nine-year-old only child and one
who felt an increasing need to be more
mature than my years i acted as calm and
cool and collected as i could
i tried to show my dad that i understood
the lessons of civics and morality that
he was trying to teach me
but it was just a calm veneer
because all i could think was if the
government was shooting these people for
standing up for what they believed in
would they shoot me or even my dad
it was a terrifying thought that now
echoed in the back of my mind
the next stop on our summer of 72 tour
was summerfest in milwaukee
summerfest is basically an ocean of beer
surrounding an island of sausage
[Laughter]
you know what they call good clean
american fun
and you know when i think good clean
american fun don't you also immediately
think george carlin
dad opened for arlo guthrie and
struggled to do his new material while
while connecting with the enormous
audience of over 10
000 people
he began to do his new routine the seven
words you can never say on television
which he just recorded on his third
album class clown
the album wouldn't be released for
another few months so i'm pretty sure
the promoter didn't know exactly what he
had signed up for when he booked my dad
the routine was both hilarious and an
intellectual examination of the usage of
language in our culture
however it consisted of words according
to my dad quote that'll infect your soul
curve your spine and keep the country
from winning the war
and the seven dirty words are you know
what they are
you want me to say them
[ __ ]
[ __ ] piss [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] in tits
uh some poor woman outside of
charlottesville watching this live just
had a stroke
i apologize to her family now
okay good
yes she has yes those words because
summerfest was an outdoor venue the main
stage act could be heard throughout the
fairgrounds
meaning it could be heard by lots of
mommies and daddies and little kitties
so there was my dad on stage killing
most of the audience was loving it while
mom and i stood in the wings also
enjoying the show
that's when the promoter rushed up to my
mom and said look the cops are here
they're complaining about the language
and they're going to arrest george the
minute he gets off stage
i guess when my dad said that he'd like
to
everyone in the audience the nice
midwestern policeman took some offense
at that
knowing that he was carrying drugs in
his pockets both grass and coke
my mom knew that she had to think fast
she grabbed a glass of water and walked
out onto the stage
dad was very confused
but took the water and mom whispered to
him exit stage left the cops are here
dad wrapped it up exited stage left and
we all quickly hustled into the dressing
room and locked the door i anxiously
watched as mom removed a very rather
large baggie of cocaine from her purse
and stashed it in a base drum
and dad took out the joint and small
vial of coke from his pockets and handed
them to the promoter the promoter was
trying to keep things calm when suddenly
there was a bang
it sounded as if a gun had gone off
i leapt into my mother's arms and began
crying hysterically
as she tried to calm me down nothing
else happened
someone said it was probably just a
balloon
someone had popped a balloon
mom dad and the promoter all laughed a
nervous laugh
but i was now unhinged terror streaked
through my body i couldn't breathe
i felt like i was going to die
and that's when the door opened my dad
walked out and within a few seconds
policemen cuffed him i screamed daddy
i was sure that i would never ever see
him again
mom held me back as i cried
i don't know how long it took but she
finally calmed me down enough so that
she could leave to get my dad out of
jail
luckily my mom knew exactly what to do
because of lenny bruce's arrest in
chicago in 1961.
you get a civil rights attorney i went
home with the promoter to his house and
family where i spent the rest of the
weekend distracting myself by swimming
with kids in something that
as a southern california girl
i had never seen before
an above ground pool
i almost didn't know what to do with it
i'm just thinking of the irony of when
this show gets broadcast about some
words you can't say on television and if
the irony of course is the thomas
jefferson center for the protection of
free expression sponsoring a program
yeah and then the seven dirty words are
boop boop boop boop
beeped
[Laughter]
the truth that there are seven words you
can't say on on on television even on
cable i guess uh or basic cable i guess
it is well that
actually that's actually the choice that
uh can be made because technically and
this is the focus of the first amendment
case in which your father's routine
seven words you can't say on television
was the focus
[Music]
for those of you who don't know there's
a very important first amendment case
which involved this routine which was
played on the radio
and basically it's set up the supreme
court came up with a new exception to
free speech if it's on
broadcast spectrum saying that the
government has greater
control
has a greater
discretion to
regulate the content if it's if it's
something that's broadcast over the
broadcast spectrum i won't go into the
details as to what that reasoning is but
his routine in terms of showing the
arbitrariness i think of yes
of this of being able to regulate what's
called indecent speech which could not
be regulated it wasn't obscene it wasn't
absolutely so that was it was a new
category of speech that had been created
this indecent speech but he was he was
proud of that yeah
well i was going to ask about that how
do you feel about the fact that his
routine and and technically i guess in
some ways you could say
it it proved his point but
in another way i mean
the free speech side lost yes yes they
did yes they did and how did your father
feel about that that decision uh well
you know
he always called it an accident of
history that he was involved in the case
he never felt like he i mean he wasn't
he you know he didn't play the album
wbai in new york played the album and i
was in the middle of afternoon the way
my dis my dad describes the moment is a
professional
um uh
moralist was in a car with his 14 year
old son when they played the seven dirty
words
like this 14 year old son had never
heard these words
and of course my dad's argument was
there are two buttons on a radio the off
switch and the one that changes the
station
if you don't like the speech choose some
different speech uh but this gentleman
decided to go and complain to the fcc
this thing ended up all the way in the
supreme court
um
my dad's biggest joy around this case
uh
was that
all nine justices had to listen
[Laughter]
to the album
to the piece that was played the seven
dirty words
and that
and that the actual routine is in is in
the annals is in the is in the books of
the supreme court
right now you can go to your local law
library and look up the case and his
routine is typed out for everyone to see
forever
uh he took great great pride in that
but he always did feel it was an
accident of history um
so at 25 i went back to ucla to get my
my bachelor's i became a communications
major and one of the classes we were
required to take was a first amendment
class which was my favorite class loved
it almost became a first amendment
lawyer like was very close
then i thought oh law school
but my professor
i'm in a classroom of about 150 you know
maybe a little bigger than this kind of
a size classroom and my professor first
day of class was talking about the class
and how he loved teaching and his name
is jeff cow and he ran the annenberg
school at usc in new clinton a big first
amendment guy and he says my favorite
thing about teaching this class is that
we'll study the pacifica versus fcc case
and i'll get to do george carlin's seven
dirty words for you
now this has become like a regular
occurrence in my life where i'm like
somewhere innocently minding my own
business
and my father intrudes on my life
and it was really one of those moments
where i saw so this was in um
80
it's about 90.
and i really saw like wow my dad's
really had this incredible impact on the
culture at large
and the fun part was was getting to go
up to the professor afterwards and going
hi
just want to let you know
uh and of course so the professor said
to me oh
could your dad come would he come
and do the seven dirty words for us so i
went to my dad and i said so i'm taking
this class and i explained the whole
thing to him and i said we're studying
the pacifica case and
the professor would really love for you
to come and my dad was so
so cute and interesting his reaction to
that was
oh no i couldn't do that i don't know
anything about the case i mean it's just
an accident of history that it was me
and blah blah blah blah and he's going
on and on about it and i just look at
him i'm like dad
i don't think they're asking you to know
the law
i think they want you to come and be
george carlin and say the seven dirty
words
but he was just so darling about and so
and i mean that was really
it really shows my father's kind of
humility my father had a lot of humility
about his place in the culture and what
he did
and um
and you know he really
he really walked that walk uh big time
and and i don't even think it was until
probably just a few years before he died
that he even was acknowledging that he
was kind of an elder statesman in the
world of comedy and that you know he
would say things like well yeah when
they talk about comedy in the second
half of the 20th century they're going
to have to mention me
and i'm like really dad you think so
so i just i just i love that about my
dad that's a side of him i mean that's
another reason i wrote this book is
that
my father everyone knows the version of
my father on stage and if you followed
his career over 40 some odd years you
saw very different versions of him on
the stage from the clean cut guy who did
the ed sullivan
and the early carson shows hippy dippy
weather man indian sergeant guy
then boom all of a sudden he's dropped
acid and he's got a beard and long hair
and he's saying the seven dirty words
and then
kind of in the 80s he's kind of
floundering a little bit and then late
80s early 90s he comes out with jamming
in new york and he's got a whole another
level of
um
political point of view and outrage
about the planet and uh
which came from him being a
brokenhearted idealist um he he voted in
72 for mcgovern and when mcgovern lost
he never voted again he believed that
the system was broken
and that's why he used to tell say to
people you know um i don't vote that way
i have a right to complain
[Laughter]
i do vote by the way and i encourage
people to vote but um
but uh i forgot my train of thought the
evolution of my dad and him growing and
no i have no idea where i was going
middle age well it's interesting that
your father was so uh humble about this
but
every time i well at least
i guess i have to qualify it but every
time i hear comedians or at least the
comedians that i really enjoy
being interviewed themselves and talking
about their influence
your father's always up there sure
him and richard are the two big ones
richard pryor bill cosby lenny bruce
people like john stewart lewis black
yeah mar yeah all these folks always
interview uh name your father as as the
person who was uh
uh most influential and it was it
your father lived long enough to know
that he had been awarded the mark twain
prize for comedy by the kennedy center
yeah but unfortunately did not live long
enough to see or attend
the aftermath ceremony yeah yeah he was
actually thrilled about that you know he
didn't really take a lot of you know
stock and awards and things like that um
but when he heard he got the mark twain
he was he was happy about that and of
course i had been secretly nominating
him for years like
come on mark twain i mean come on people
george carlin if there's not a mark
twain
in our culture i mean you know and and
they picked some other people who i get
it's a tv show and it's the kennedy
center and stuff like that but you know
and i'm a big fan of billy crystal but
really you're picking billy crystal
before george carlin for the mark twain
prize
you know so
uh
yeah he he did he he did know that and
uh
he uh he he really did appreciate it he
loved it well when when your father
passed away and this is the story about
how we met um i was a big fan of george
carlin and and since he was
so associated with the first amendment
both because of his case and a number of
other routines that he had he had done
we immediately posted on the thomas
jefferson website
sort of a tribute to george carlin
unbeknownst to me
um
kelly carlin at george carlin's funeral
there were two organizations that were
uh
that suggested that you might want to
donate to these organizations in lieu of
flowers or tributes one was the american
heart association which makes sense but
the other was the thomas jefferson
center for the protection of free
expression which i had no idea george
carlin here's what's behind the scenes
no idea that george carlin had ever
heard of us and maybe he didn't but i
got a phone call
and
our administrative assistant put it
through and said uh kelly carlin is on
the phone and i
didn't know your name at the time
and you i picked the phone and you
introduced yourself as george carlin's
daughter and i called him because i
wanted to let him know if you get some
donations in my dad's name i want you to
know why
because i've decided that you're the
organization that i'm going to tell
people to donate to well apparently
those kelly your father was a a a big
believer in the underdog yes and that's
why i picked you guys we could have
picked aclu or pen or all great
organizations but my dad was always
um loved the underdog and i thought oh
here's a here's a nice little
organization
what you told me also was that you
looked it up you're looking up
researching organizations and you talked
to thomas jefferson center and because
we just posted it there was a photo of
your dad yeah right there synchronicity
in that was too much i was like
this is this is fate this is fake yeah
these people these people are good well
once i realized she wasn't something it
wasn't a friend putting me on you know
that george carlin's daughter
i was just so excited i was so thrilled
and so honored and then typical of me
sort of going too far and putting my
foot in my mouth i said gosh i can't
tell you what a great day this is this
is like two days
two days after her father had passed
away and she was grinning but then i
knew it was really new it was george
carlin's daughter when i went oh god i
realized what i just said
and i hear this laughter on the other
end of the other end of the line that
you appreciated and you said your father
would have appreciated that moment abso
absolutely absolutely
but you obviously share up for our own
things you share your father's uh
commitment dark humor
that too that too
and maybe in that that there lies the
first amendment but your your concern
about
censorship and people the government
telling you what you can and can't say
uh yeah i mean i think that for that um
that that class i took at ucla really
taught me
a great understanding about
well constitutional law in general but
the first i mean obviously watching my
father get arrested for saying the seven
dirty words and hearing lenny bruce's
story all the time your whole life
you're a person who's
interested in language and censorship uh
but um i think the thing that
is most important i mean it is the first
amendment like that's that's a little
hint right there
it's not the sixth it's the first one
and uh you know when i when i got to
learn that we had to argue cases on both
sides as you have to do in law school
also we had to argue both sides of the
argument in these first amendment cases
in this class
and um i really learned that even though
i don't agree with your speech
uh i you know i will fight for the right
for you to parade down you know if it's
like the kkk in skokie illinois a famous
case you know it's like and here we are
in america in 2016 dealing with this
issue all over again and it's it's great
because i think it's a great teaching
moment for our country to talk about
speech and what is a legal speech in
legal speech and hate speech and
inciting violence and all sorts of
things um
so it's it's a really essential
essential conversation that we need to
be having as citizens and all citizens
should really understand
uh their constitution and and and all
the arguments uh involved in it um i i
want to be prescient of time here and i
know we have a clip of my dad and so i
wanted to set up the clip
um so this is uh
later in my dad's life this is 2006 it's
a few years before he um before he died
and and then we're gonna it'll lead
right into this clip that we're gonna
play here
uh
bob is the name of my husband
in november 2005 bob and i flew to new
york to see my dad shoot his 13th hbo
special
life is worth losing
i was excited my dad rarely let me
glimpse his new material before he shot
it for hbo
he liked having me experience the
material in its full and polished form
it was always a thrill for me to sit in
the audience not knowing what was coming
this year i was especially looking
forward to seeing him we'd both been
really busy and i hadn't when we hadn't
seen each other in about three months
after walking up the stairs backstage at
the beacon theater i caught my breath
and walked into his dressing room i saw
a short white-haired man with his back
to me when he turned around it was my
dad
i was stunned
who took my father and left this elderly
man in his place
my dad's face was puffy he was two
inches shorter and he looked like he was
fighting to breathe
what the hell
i noticed the last few times i talked
with him on the phone that he'd been a
bit scatterbrained
very unlike my dad
he'd forgotten the name of his assistant
once and one day he didn't show up at a
breakfast we'd planned
i thought at the time it must be his age
but seeing him now backstage
i knew something was really wrong
people don't age this quickly i didn't
say anything to him not wanting to
distract him from the task ahead that
night
but as i walked in my seat in the
audience i worried if he'd be able to
make it through the show
i steeled myself for the worst
would he be okay
would the audience respond to how he
looked
might he even collapse
but
when he took the stage that night
he came alive
and all i could think was
if he could just stay there
he just might live forever
could you play the clip
oh you're going to play it here
yeah this is dangerous they put me in
charge of this
there you go this will this will
demonstrate about george carlin's love
of language
that he passed on we got from his mother
and passed on to his
daughter
and that's not it i thought that
good [ __ ]
yep
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
i'm a modern man a man for the
millennium digital and smoke free a
diversified multicultural post-modern
deconstruction is politically
anatomically and ecologically incorrect
i've been uplinked and downloaded i've
been inputted and outsourced and all the
upside of downsizing i know the downside
of upgrading i'm a high-tech low-life a
cutting edge state-of-the-art bike
coastal multi-tasker and i can give you
a gigabyte in a nano second
i'm new wave but i'm old school and my
inner child is outward bound i'm a
hot-wired heat-seeking warm-hearted cool
customer voice activated and
biodegradable i interface in my database
my databases in cyberspace so i'm
interactive i'm hyperactive and from
time to time i'm radioactive
[Music]
behind the eight ball ahead of the curve
riding the wave dodging the bullet
pushing the envelope i'm on point on
task on messaging off drugs i got no
need for coke and speed i got no urge to
binge and purge i'm in the moment on the
edge over the top but under the radar a
high concept low profile medium range
ballistic missionary a streetwise smart
bomb a top gun bottom feeder i wear
power ties that tell power lies i take
power naps i run victory laps i'm a
totally ongoing bigfoot slam dunk
rainmaker with a proactive outreach a
raging workaholic a working rangerholic
out of rehab and in denial
[Applause]
i got a personal trainer a personal
shopper a personal assistant and a
personal agenda you can't shut me up you
can't dumb me down because i'm tireless
and i'm wireless i'm an alpha male on
beta blockers
[Applause]
i'm a non-believer and an overachiever
laid back but fashion forward upfront
down home low rent high maintenance
super size long lasting high definition
fast acting oven ready and built to last
i'm a hands on foot loose knee jerk head
case prematurely post traumatic and i
have a love child who sends me hate mail
but i'm feeling i'm caring i'm healing
i'm sharing a supportive bonding
nurturing primary caregiver my output is
down but my income is up i take a short
position on the long bond and my revenue
stream has its own cash flow i read junk
mail i eat junk food i buy junk bonds i
watch trash sports i'm gender specific
capital intensive user friendly and
lactose intolerant
[Applause]
i like rough sex i like rough sex i like
tough love i use the f-word in my email
and the software on my hard drive is
hardcore no soft porn
i bought a microwave at a mini mall i
bought a minivan in a mega store i eat
fast food in the slow lane i'm toll free
bite size ready to wear and i come in
all sizes
a fully equipped factory authorized
hospital tested clinically proven
scientifically formulated medical
miracle have been pre-washed pre-cooked
pre-heated pre-screened pre-approved
pre-packaged post-dated freeze-dried
double-wrapped vacuum pack and i have an
unlimited broadband capacity
i'm a rude dude but i'm the real deal
lean and mean [ __ ] locked and ready to
rock rough tough and hard to bluff i
take it slow i go with the flow i ride
with the tide i got glide in my stride
driving and moving sailing and spinning
jiving and grooving wailing and winning
i don't snooze so i don't lose i keep
the pedal to the metal and the rubber on
the road i party hearty and lunch time
is crunch time i'm hanging in there
ain't no doubt and i'm hanging tough
over and out
i just want to read this one little bit
that comes right after this
so a month after this uh
he really couldn't breathe
christmas eve morning sally called kelly
we're at cedars-sinai hospital george is
in the emergency room
bob and i raced north on la siena
boulevard and found sally in the waiting
room my dad's girlfriend shaken up
they've stabilized him he's doing better
about 20 minutes later the er doctor
came out
he's doing much better than when he came
in we gave him some medicine lasix to
help remove some of the fluid from his
lungs and stabilize the heart failure
the what
heart failure
that's what had been going on with him
in new york heart failure
it is a condition they could stabilize
with medicine for a few years but
eventually only a heart transplant would
fix it permanently
after a while they let me see him
as i sat alone with him in the emergency
room he admitted to me that he'd had
symptoms for months and months and had
ignored them so that he could do his hbo
special
i wanted to kill him
but on the other hand
i got it
it was a great show
as he lay there dozing i sat at the foot
of his bed with my hands on his feet
meditating and sending him as much life
force as i could
i was doing my best to uphold my shaman
duties my dad called me the shaman of
the family
i'd never felt so peaceful in his
presence before there was a sweetness to
it
a week later they released him from the
hospital but now he had a device
implanted in his chest
it was a combination pacemaker heart
pump and defibrillator
dad was oddly proud of this device
because he bragged it's the exact same
device they implanted the chest of dick
cheney
[Laughter]
my dad died a few years later and
there's the ending of the book i don't
want to i don't want to give it away but
we had a great chance to
heal and then come together we would
already healed a lot of our past and
stuff but just an amazing ending
happened for us uh one that
fits well with the beginning of our
story it feels almost like a
mythological legend in some ways and uh
so i feel very
lucky and full of a lot of gratitude
that um
i got to heal with my parents and we got
to love each other and laugh with each
other through all of the insanity and
the roller coaster ride of our lives
and uh and i and i'm really i'm so
honored to be able to tell my story to
everyone
and to share pieces of my dad that
people don't get otherwise i think that
was the point i wanted to make earlier
that part of the reason i wanted to
write this book was they they see one
version of my dad on stage that guy but
they don't know the husband and the
father and the man and the artist the
struggling artist and i it's just a
great privilege to be able to share that
part of my dad with the world so
um if you guys have any questions we'd
love to take some questions
yes ma'am can we bring the mic to
what are you can you hold on they'll
help they they want that for them
i'll just say just say one thing as the
microphone is making its round one of
the things i really enjoy about this
book is is learning a lot more about
george carlin but even if you don't know
anything about george carlin this is a
wonderful book to read for all of the
other uh
aspects of your your story um but not
not just about you but your mother is a
fascinating character yeah i wanted to
give my mother voice i'd like to talk
about yeah i wish we had time to talk
about the influence that she had on you
and and what she her her survivor story
yeah um
and it's it's it's always fun
to
learn and see from a different
perspective somebody you think you know
and then but then you see it an entirely
different aspect of george carlin's um
um life and character um from reading
this book but also just this whole story
of this this unique this unique
story your story yeah and um
it's just a very very enlightening and
also very entertaining read so i
i strongly call it a page turner i
strongly
strongly leave little cliffhangers at
the end of each chapter oh you must go
to the next chapter now
well i'll just i'll just tell you what
bill maher says one hell of a ride kelly
carlin gives great insight into a man
who was a hero to many but a father to
one
um and it really is just a wonderful
wonderful read so i strongly encourage
everybody to buy a copy if they'd like
this paperback is coming out soon if you
if you want to wait
but uh i've always been a big influence
in terms of what people choose to buy
and read no just
um but but firm if you if you take the
advice of complete strangers that's
probably not a good idea but i highly do
highly recommend this book let's turn to
you have a question yes
what do you think your father would make
of today's political situation
shocking i got that question
i get that question 10 times a day on
twitter
um well first of all he'd love it
he'd absolutely love it he loved
here's here's here's what i tell people
say to people i say look this is what my
dad said he said when you're born
you get a ticket to the freak show
when you're when you're born in america
you get a front row seat
and it feels like this
day and age uh we're all in the vip
section
[Laughter]
uh he'd love it he'd love it he uh died
june 22nd 2008 he didn't get to see
obama become president
uh he was excited though he was excited
about hillary being you know being a
possibility first female president and
then
obama started getting some traction
right around then and my dad was excited
uh when i went to washington dc to do
the mark twain prize
um my husband and i uh went to the
lincoln memorial and we were standing on
the steps
and uh the presidential helicopter went
over our heads
and it was obama visiting the white
house for the first time
and i just i cried
such tears for my father because my
father would have been my father was a
huge
advocate
having grown up in harlem
and
black culture and black music if you
know his earlier class clown album stuff
he talks about it a lot occupation fool
was a huge influence on him and uh he
was absolutely just
you know he would have been thrilled to
have seen that happen so but but
nowadays he'd be thr he'd
oh the show the spectacle of it all
yeah so you know i wish he was here to
give us the more specifics
because he would have a unique take on
it that no one else has come up with uh
but i feel that we're in you know as far
as satirical comedy goes we're still in
really good hands there's a lot of great
satirical comics out there who do
political work and who are if you
haven't seen samantha bee's new full
frontal show
highly highly recommended i think she's
uh she's my front runner right now i
love her
someone else question right here i
learned a new expression this week
post-traumatic thriving
and i wonder i would love you to share
your experience strength and hope about
post-traumatic thriving oh that's so
that's so beautiful uh yay let's reframe
that
uh yeah there's
you know i think part of it is you know
we're kind of lucky with our genetics
we get some thriving genes some
resilience genes i come from really good
stock
uh and um there's something about love
i was really lucky to know that no
matter all the chaos in my life in my
childhood especially from age five to to
twelve i knew i was loved deeply loved
and there's something about that
early childhood attachment theory they
talk about that is real
uh so i knew i was ultimately safe
uh
it took me a while to ultimately figure
that out as an adult i mean i did have
panic attack syndrome and agoraphobia
for a few for 10 years
uh but
um
there is something about that and at
some point
in all of our healing process
you need to move from
the
and it's important to feel your pain to
feel your rage to feel the place of
victimhood that you are because you were
a child you have completely powerless
into okay now what
that's a really important shift
in in a life and in a healing
and uh because it's ultimately it is our
life and we're adults and we have to
take responsibility for it and i had to
learn uh to take responsibility for my
anxiety and my depression and my life
and what i was gonna do with it and it
was terrifying and confusing but
um
[Music]
it's the only thing that really saved my
life ultimately so thank you for that
question
question hello hi kelly i'm wendy
edwards with newsradio 1070 winna in
98.9 fm
and uh my question for you is when it
comes to dad isms that especially in
your teenage years made you like roll
your eyes and groan like dad are you
saying this to me again what would that
be that would probably be the correcting
of my my pronunciation and stuff like
that i mean my dad was the coolest dad
ever i mean hello
when i was in high school we shared weed
[Laughter]
kind of hard to roll your eyes at that
kind of a dad
you know and i think my my parents were
that first generation where it was
really confusing for parents because
they had partied a lot and they didn't
quite know how to and they didn't buy
into the just say no campaign and it was
actually before that that i was in high
school i was in high school in the late
70s so they really couldn't put their
foot down and say
uh do i wish they had a little bit more
yeah wish they had created more limits
for me and more rules uh probably would
have saved me uh 10 years of my life in
my 20s but uh once again they didn't and
i had to learn from that but
um
yeah my dad was a god to me
you know and uh
is still a god to a lot of people
um i've had to learn to take him off the
pedestal and realize he's human but uh
yeah i think for the most part it was
that kind of
his
you know wanting to
control my speech
which is so ironic
[Laughter]
sure right here
so first of all thank you very much for
being here thank you very much for
writing this book and sharing insights
into someone that i know many of us in
here miss desperately yes
um in the c-ville this week there was a
blurb on this particular session and
there was a comment about
uh george's commitment to truth yes in
everything he said
and one of my earliest memories of
george carlin was his description of a
tomato which i thought was just so
dead-on truthful i barely eat them still
because of that description can you talk
about you know that that aspect yes the
truth and honesty beautiful i would love
to so something we actually didn't get a
chance to talk about here uh it's
another big theme of my book
uh first of all the description of the
tomato that he's talking about if you
don't know it is my dad con considered
it a food that was not finished
it was still undone had not finished
developing
my other favorite food thing was he
never ate anything that he had to break
into its house to eat
like a clam or something like that
i love that i don't eat clams or oysters
because of that he was very influential
in my life
one of the ironies of the carlin
household and one of the themes of this
book is truth telling
and my father was the truth-teller to
quite a few generations
um
but growing up in an alcoholic
drug-addicted dysfunctional household
truth is a slippery slope
[Laughter]
and
um it was confusing for me as a kid
because uh
with dysfunction comes denial
and denial is about ignoring the truth
the big elephant in the room
and so insane things would go on in my
life
a very famous story i tell is my father
waking me up one morning
this was in the mid 70s
and
we just been to hawaii on a hawaiian
vacation my dad came into my room and
woke me up and said kelly
um
uh
i need you to wake up i i think the sun
has exploded and we have about seven
minutes to live
and my father had been up for about five
days doing a lot of coke and he was
hallucinating and he was he was screwed
up and we went outside and it was it was
kind of hazy weird sun and stuff but
anyway my point is that i couldn't go to
school
on monday and when i was asked about
easter vacation how it was i couldn't
say well my dad's freaking out on drugs
and
my mom and dad almost tried to kill each
other with knives and you know i i
couldn't speak the truth
so i had this very
difficult relationship with learning
what my truth was and how to express
myself my emotions and
reality
there wasn't a lot of reality going on
uh i was living a parallel life i i
started living that's when i started
living a parallel life which is my my
persona and then my private life
and that got me into a lot of trouble
when i got into an abusive relationship
because i didn't tell anyone about it
for two years in high school it got me
into trouble when i was doing uh way too
much cocaine and knew i needed help it
got me into trouble when i was
agoraphobia and i couldn't get in my car
and drive around and couldn't explain to
people why i was no longer leaving my
house so it you know it's a very
delicate thing and one of the things
that happened with my dad and i was that
um
i in 99 had written a one-woman show
because i wanted to talk about my mother
and her death and how it transformed me
and part of it was i wanted to talk
about my childhood and how
how that was a part of shaping me
and
how difficult that was for my dad when i
said i want to do this show and he
he um part of it was difficult because i
talked about things in the show that i'd
never actually talked to my dad about
before
feelings i had about some things that
had gone on
and he said to me like why did i have to
read your script to find out about this
and i s you know and i said well maybe
maybe i felt like i had to be on your
stage for you to finally hear me
um
you know truth
so that's something my dad and i that it
was a healing my dad and i had in our
life was we got to actually talk to each
other and learn
to share the scary things inside of us
that all of us humans go through and
share our feelings um but yeah truth
truth is interesting
[Laughter]
it is relative at times how do you think
just for your information sorry to butt
in back in the questioning but
you've also done a one-woman show yeah
i'm doing a solo show now that i too
were a little bit yeah which which i was
fortunate to see um in los angeles and
it it's really a parallel uh to this
yeah it's the scaffolding for this book
this book's much more in-depth but yeah
there's a lot there how do you
how do you think your father would feel
about that show because that was written
of course after his passing yeah you
know it started earlier i think that um
[Music]
you know
i think part of my role in the family is
to
if he was alive and i was doing it i
mean first i don't know if that would be
possible because of a lot of what i say
in the there's times in the book where i
talk about how i back away from telling
my story while he's alive for different
reasons
um
but
i really see now that my role
in the world
as a truth-teller because my dad did
teach me to be a truth-teller is to
speak my truth and to talk about our our
shared humanity
uh and that we're all broken and we're
all messed up and we're all just trying
to figure it out and that's why i want
to tell my story because i want i want
people to feel safe to tell their
stories whether it's to their loved ones
or on a stage or or wherever it is
we're only as sick as our secrets as
they say naa
and um
so i think in the end i think my father
would be very proud of me because
um i have figured out what my role is as
a truth-teller and that i'm and this is
not an i mean and there's nothing daddy
dearest in this book at all when this
book first came out some people were
like
my daddy here's you know trolls on the
internet and i'm like really have you
read the book do you know anything about
it there's so much love in this book
there's not a moment of complaining or
victimhood so um
and i think my dad would get one thing i
say in the solo show is that you know
when people come to see my show or read
my book they always love my dad so much
more than they used to because now he's
a whole person to them
and only once at a speaking gig how did
a guy come up to me
[Laughter]
and say oh i gotta tell you i've lost
respect for your dad now that i know
that he you know he he you know that he
he couldn't function that well as a
human and stuff and i was like wow dude
that says a lot more about you than it
does
well i think i think the the cover photo
that you chose for the book just says so
much about your relationship i mean you
can just see it yes this picture it's
just i'm a daddy even if you don't buy
the book
come up and look at this photograph
next question right here thank you yes
coming back to your reminding us of what
the seven words are yeah you can't say i
was thinking i wonder how they're going
to subtitle that if someone is running
subtitles as they watch the television
but then that led me to thinking about
what publications do where they will
take those seven letters seven words and
they will print the first letter right
xxx or ask we don't know what they're
saying but this is more a first
amendment question than than anything
else
the question is what's the point yeah
and what kind of trouble would a
publication a general purpose
publication get in for actually shocking
the world with the full spelling of
those seven words well i'd actually if
you were here i i'd appoint i have uh
john jeffries former dean of the law
school also a member of the center's
board of trustees professor of the
school answer that question so i'm very
nervous in answering myself because i
probably get it wrong but the fact is
in a publication that's probably a
question of choice by the publication
they it would be very difficult under
first amendment law to get in any
trouble for particularly if they're
talking about it in this context
but to use those words
in a publication or something like that
that would not meet the definition of
obscenity the indecency provision only
applies to broadcasting this lesser
protecting of speech so it's basically a
an area of law it's not uh the actual
content
it it a big part of the the definition
is where
it's being done and in fact um here's
where i think i'm i think i'm right john
but um
uh
the words that we said here
when you see the daily show with jon
stewart and they bleep those words out
or cable television or satellite
television that's really a question of
choice the choice of the the the people
who are producing the show it's not a
requirement because those shows aren't
presented to you
via the broadcast spectrum
i won't go too much into the weeds as to
why the government has that that greater
control but it's an interesting
development because
i don't think any of us today think
about oh this is this is a cable access
television show as opposed to nbc access
television right
but that that is therein lies the
difference as to why you can the
government can have greater control
over um
uh broadcast spectrum and that that
indecency provision only
uh
as a matter of law applies uh if it is
on the broadcast spectrum john is that
correct
and what always gets me about this when
i you read the word well you're reading
the word the word is being said in your
head so it's not like you're going wow i
wonder what that word is
maybe it's spot
or fork
you know it's just so silly well it's
it's uh we were just talking about this
dude there used to there's a television
show on recently a few years ago
battle star galactica which was a
took place you know human humanoid
beings but in another universe
they the way they got around this
was they created their own curse words
and their own indecent words and the
word was fracking now just imagine
another word a decent word
now imagine a word that begins with f
that many of us might be offended by but
just use liberally oh i don't give a
frac why don't you go frack yourself all
of this i mean they just completely
because it was a different culture
that's great the other thing interesting
about your thing is in virginia beach
there's an ordinance which i think is
incredibly unconstitutional local
ordinance but that you can't curse in
public they're more of these than you
think yeah yeah and it's it's still on
the books let's go test it but it does
but
on street signs in virginia there's the
exactly the kind of thing you see where
you see the little like asterisk and
pound sign for cuss words so only
they're all put up there and then
there's a red circle with a line through
it
and it's posted a go walk down virginia
beach and in the streets and you'll see
those signs there and people are fine
for those for violating that
next question yes my friend cheryl hello
kelly hello darling i'm glad you're here
i'm curious
because i actually don't know the answer
is
back in the day before paparazzi was as
big as it is today
was your family unit
ever no we were so late we were so lucky
we never were
i think because of my dad wasn't part of
the pop culture
we never were the
the sickest thing about tabloid stuff is
that the one time we showed up there
is when my mother was dying of liver
cancer and and we were in the national
enquirer for that and i was just like oh
you've got to be
kidding me i'm just horrific
uh but now we're very lucky very lucky
that in my teenage years
there was nothing like that really
around yet
as i was hanging out i went to school in
la with all sorts of celebrities kids
and we were doing
a lot of illegal things
a lot of drugs and stuff and just crazy
teenage stuff and uh thank god we
weren't
being
it's not like the kardashians or
anything and thank god there was no
facebook but yeah we were always very
protected
and um
you know really back in the day like
when we knew cheryl's a friend of mine
from venice we lived there in the early
early 70s together
um during that time what was really
dangerous was the cops i mean you know
that's was more dangerous in our family
than anything was
feeling like my dad could be arrested at
any moment because he usually was going
to be
[Laughter]
but yeah i'm really glad there wasn't
thank god anyone else
hi kelly hi kiva um
yesterday we did a great podcast and i'm
with the thomas jefferson center as well
and kelly came on and discussed a lot of
things that you didn't hear today so if
you want to go listen to it it's the
muzzled podcast but one of the things
that i think
fascinated me the most was the response
both of his fans after his death to you
um and kind of disparate responses as
well as the response of the um comedy
community which you had not before been
apart yeah
uh
so
before my dad died i was not
i'd watch a little bit of comedy it was
my dad's job and my dad was like did
theaters so we didn't go to comedy clubs
growing there were no comedy clubs when
i was growing up it wasn't a thing
so i didn't know a lot of comedians i
think i knew one or two maybe uh and
when my dad died uh
comedians started calling me immediately
the next day
and
i found myself you know sitting on the
floor of my bathroom crying into the
phone with gary shandling one morning
um
and it was really an incredible thing
because the comedy family
a lot of comedians who
you talked about um some of them
uh who really my dad was like their
father great uncle of comedy
and uh they all said to me
um we're here for you
uh we know you're alone
and we are your family now and if you
ever need anything
please pick up the phone and call us
and so that was an incredible feeling
because my dad you know was this huge
he was the son of my solar system and
you know here he was gone
and then because social media became a
thing that summer 2008 was really when i
got involved in facebook uh
and it really became a thing uh his fans
found me and
um
the first year and a half or two
i don't know what i would have done
without the fans because they really
lifted me up and they loved me
unconditionally and they took me in
uh and really
and we shared we shared everything about
my dad i could have conversations with
them about them and we could share his
humor and his his material and his stuff
and
you know
in some ways i had to eventually
grow out of that and and
walk out of the shadow of that a little
bit but
um in order for my sanity but
but really i felt like they it was like
this beautiful
web of of love and light that it caught
me and kept my head just above the water
of grief for a few years so that i
didn't completely disappear into it and
it's really an interesting thing about
grief um as many of you know it's it's a
it's a very unique process
but now that the book is out which was
came out last september
i feel like on some level that
i'm done being george carlin's daughter
i mean i'm still am but that i'm
actually able to now have my own time of
personal grief that i don't have to be
on display anymore and even though i do
events like this and and do my show a
little bit that there's a private space
for me now because there's this there's
the public thing here so it's just a
it's a fascinating it's been a fast i've
been watching my journey it's been very
fascinating so
um we have a few more minutes oh time we
got a time from the the tea lady that
the tea lady okay we're good yeah we're
gonna i'm gonna sign some books if
someone wants to buy some books i'll
sign them or whatever and we'll meet and
we'll take before the selfies yes before
we cut off yes please fill out an
evaluation i'm told to do that your
evaluation you can turn your cell phones
back on
but the other thing i was going to say
petition whatever local theater
paramount or something to have to have
the play version of this book to sign up
to bring bring this to charlottesville
it's such an entertaining production
thank you all for coming thank you
oh